hello you guys are cute walking out here
with your hats and your whole you're
very cool rock and roll country I'm into
it oh my goodness thank you and
congratulations thank you yes so such an
exciting time love is blooming I heard
that a dog introduced y'all is that can
I meet the dog maybe it can help me it
is actually the like funny story cuz I
was walking out of an audition um on the
sunset go lot in Hollywood and Billy's
dog at the time Tex who was the most
beautiful German Shepherd you've ever
seen he was tapped into some Divine
Purpose because we were you know at the
time just friends and all these years
later that was like 14 years
ago yeah all these years later we just
got married oh I love dogs they're the
best so wait so I love your accent I
love Australia as well sorry I'm
focusing on her I'm just like just for a
minute no I just um I love all star so
much so what what made you want to move
here honestly Kelly like I had this
weird desire my whole life that was like
this burning desire to come to America I
can't even explain where it came from
except pop music was like my
spirituality I just felt like this
calling when I listen to a song your
songs which I'm trying to like
completely freak out but you are keeping
it cool ma' you're yeah you you are one
of my absolute idols and L to your music
um growing up in Australia I just like
literally felt this calling that I just
knew in my spirit that I belonged in
America purpose so at 19 I just got on a
plane and um and never looked back like
yeah I did the same thing like 18 I
drove um and everyone was like what are
you doing but I drove from Texas to LA
and just lived on a mattress and work
cuz I knew I was like this has got to be
it there's no backup plan I hope it
works
literally like there's no backup
[Music]
plan
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home